hey what's up guys my name is Deshawn
and welcome back to my safe wealth loss
series so today we're going to be
talking all about static analysis in say
plus plus something that is going to
help you improve your code
I think one of the most common questions
that I get is how can I make my card
better how can I write code that
produces fewer bugs now ideally we would
be just amazing programmers to write
flawless code our brains would just be
able to compute everything on the fly we
would know exactly what we're writing if
there's some kind of error we could just
foresee all of this stuff happening but
the reality is that's hard even for an
experienced programmer who's been
working for decades and is very well
aware of how computers work there's
still gonna be stuff that you miss and
that's where you can use a tool called a
static analyzer to actually look at your
source code and try and find problems
with it now I think the best way to look
at this is to think of yourself writing
a word document maybe you're writing
some kind of paper or an essay or some
kind of report if you're writing that in
English or whatever your native language
is chances are you're pretty good at
that language I mean I would probably
expect a native English speaker to be
better at English than they are at C++
at least I hope so
and of course this translates to
whatever your native language is but the
point is you're probably very good at
that language you probably understand
how spelling and grammar work and you're
a lot more used to writing in that
language then you probably are writing
in a programming language such as C++
but even though you're very familiar
with language that you're writing that
document in you still typically use the
spelling and grammar checking tools
inside your word processor whether that
be Microsoft Word or Google Docs or
something like that spelling mistakes
and grammar errors or just phrases that
don't seem to make sense are underlined
for you and I imagine that you probably
wouldn't want to write a serious
document without having those tools
available to you you probably wouldn't
trust yourself to get all of the
spelling 100% right and all of the
grammar 100% right why don't have this
little tool that just sits there and
checks your work to make sure that it's
correct now if we're so eager to rely on
a tool like that to check our native
language for errors
wouldn't it make sense to also have
something like that for whatever
programming language we're using I mean
considering that you're probably more
likely to make a mistake in C++ instead
of in English for example especially if
you're less experienced in the language
and especially if that language tends to
be C++ now programming is a little bit
different of course if you accidentally
misspelled a variable name in one place
after it's already been declared and
defined that's probably going to result
in a compiler error you're just not
going to be able to compile your code
into a program because the compiler
won't be able to make sense of what
you've written that's a little bit
different and if you're writing a Word
document now grammar mistakes on the
other hand and I'm not talking about the
actual like a lexical grammar of the
language of C++ I'm more or less talking
about you know the intended usage of the
code that we've written those mistakes a
compiler is never gonna catch because
the compiler doesn't really know what
you're trying to do and in fact is job
is not to try and predict what you're
trying to do and try and find mistakes
in that it just needs to make sure that
your code is able to be compiled into
some kind of binary format that might be
executed might be used elsewhere it's
not going to actually dive into your
code and analyze it and try and make
sure that what you've actually written
physically in the code is what your
intention was and that is exactly where
a static analyzer comes in a static
analyzer will actually look at your code
and try and detect various errors that
you may have unintentionally written
kind of like a code review but instead
of a person doing it the tool is just
gonna do it for you I honestly think
that pretty much everyone would benefit
from static analysis if you just took a
static analyzer and ran it through your
code I am sure that it would point out a
few things that are at best questionable
and at worst just may completely wreck
your life if you don't fix them
immediately and it's also quite a big
deal in the games industry for example
Unreal Engine uses static analysis John
Carmack has mentioned one of the most
important things that he's done in
recent years has been to pursue static
analysis so my point is that it can be
an absolutely useful asset to you and in
fact of course it never hurts to get an
additional set of eyes looking at your
code now there are a lot of different
static analyzers out there and I
encourage you guys to check all of them
out
but today we're gonna be specifically
talking about PBS studio who are also
nice enough to sponsor this video I've
talked about PBS studio before it's one
of my favorite static analyzers you guys
can check out this video from a while
back where I actually used it on hazel a
little bit it's incredibly
straightforward verbose and just I mean
it just works it just finds a lot of
errors in your code what I want to do is
dive into some C++ code and just show
you some very basic examples of how to
get started using it as some of the
stuff that it can actually detect PBS
studio comes in a variety of flavors one
of which is a fantastic Visual Studio
extension and that's what we'll be using
today it's also worthwhile to mention
that PBS studio supports C C++ C sharp
and Java but today of course we'll be
using it with C++ code after installing
PBS studio under extensions and then PBS
studio you'll see basically all of the
options that they offer if you go to
options there's also a ton of various
settings that you can actually modify
the most common tools that I tend to use
are the check current file which is just
a little quick check to see what might
be wrong with the current file and also
check current project or even solution
which will actually check all of your
code now there are a ton of different
things that PBS studio will actually
detect I'm not gonna attempt to show you
guys like all of them or anything like
that I'll just show you some of the
stuff that it detects that I think is
really really useful and probably quite
common so suppose that I need to write a
nested for loop because I want to fill
some kind of maybe like a color buffer
full of like pixel color values I might
have some kind of buffer that I've
created here I might just make this a
pointer and allocated on the heap here
there's going to be a certain width
maybe 800 and a height that I set up
here I'll allocate width times height
here not forgetting this equal sign and
then I might choose to write some kind
of for loop which just iterates through
maybe the width and the height maybe
nested inside each other to try and fill
the buffer with a certain color value
maybe black so what I'll do is I'll
write the outer for loop first I'll say
for you and 32t y equals zero Y is less
than height Y plus plus and then of
course for the inner loop I'll just copy
this and I'll write it out like this so
we'll change this to X and X is less
than width etc okay and then we'll just
do buffer X plus y times width equals
maybe
like zero so we're just clearing it to
zero and of course we could just use a
ma'am set for this but that's not the
point we're demonstrating a nested for
loop example so what we've done here is
we've actually made a small little
mistake something that is not very
apparent especially because we copied
and pasted the code let's go ahead and
go to extensions PVS studio and check
the current file so PBS studio will open
over here we'll see a little prompt here
for a second and then we'll get the
errors showing up here so it seems to
say two things first of all the
condition ax less than width of loop is
always true so we can double click on it
it will actually highlight it for us
okay that's interesting and then we have
another one which is a little bit more
descriptive for this particular case it
says here that it is likely that a wrong
variable is being incremented inside the
for operator consider reviewing why so
if we double click on this we can look
at this and we can consider reviewing
why oh look we've accidentally written Y
here because I copied and pasted this
code and I must have forgotten to change
this from Y to X this is honestly an
issue that happens more often than you
think I've made this mistake countless
times not necessarily with a nested for
loop like this but copying and pasting
code is something that is this is
completely common in the life of a
programmer you're continually copying
and pasting code and accidentally
forgetting to maybe change all of the
variables is an issue and little
mistakes like these can actually just
fly by until maybe a month later they'll
explode somewhere you might even
accidentally ship code with this it
really is a big deal and it's something
that we miss all the time now in this
case PBS studio actually gave us two
different error messages so the
condition ax less than width of loop is
always true this is pretty cool it means
that since we've actually set X to 0 and
then we're evaluating X less than width
but then whenever incrementing X it
means that we're never going to satisfy
the condition of this loop X will always
remain at zero and thus we've created an
infinite loop and PBS is actually able
to detect all of that it basically
execute our code inside its little
engine and sees what the output will
likely be and that's one of the most
powerful features of PBS the fact that
it has this little internal engine that
it can actually use to evaluate our code
it's really cool so with this in mind I
can come in and I can just change this X
here
and then I can validate this code once
more through PBS studio and now we can
see that we have no error messages cool
let's look at another example a lot of
the time when we're dealing with strings
particularly like raw strings maybe we
have like a Const our string here and it
just says hello when we're dealing with
strings something that programmers tend
to do quite often is completely forget
about the null termination character
meaning that this little backslash 0 is
actually inside this buffer if you take
a look at the length of this string it's
going to give you a value of 5 because
it is 5 characters long however the
buffer required to actually store this
should be 6 bytes why because we have
the 5 letters but then we also need that
null termination character if we don't
have that and then the next byte is just
some other memory we have no way of
actually telling how big the string is
is the next byte going to be part of the
string or is it something else entirely
however it's very common to forget about
that and PBS studio is really good at
detecting exactly this I'll show you
guys an example what I might do is
attempt to create another buffer here
I'll say new char and then maybe what I
do is I'll just measure the length of
the string and I'll forget the plus 1 so
instead of making sure that I've got the
length the string plus one more bite for
the null termination character I will
forget that and then what I'll attempt
to do is use string copy to actually
copy our original string into that
buffer so I'll write buffer as the
destination and string as the source now
if I run this through PVS studio by
going to extensions PPS to do a check
current file it's telling me here that a
call of the string copy function will
lead to overflow of the buffer buffer so
if I double click on this you can see
that it doesn't like the way that I've
used this function because it's going to
overflowed this actual buffer I could
also try and use mem copy instead if I
just do mem copy buffer source and then
may be luscious through string length of
string let's try and check that out
you can see that it actually gives us an
even more descriptive error saying that
the mem copy function doesn't copy the
whole string use string copy slash
string copy s function to preserve
terminal null so it's telling us here
that we're actually not copying the
entire string because that null
termination character at the end we're
not actually preserving it again really
important stuff that you could just like
to get this code and everything would
run fine but of course you are missing
that a null termination character in
fact you haven't even allocated enough
room for
and these are all things that PBS studio
can detect the last example that I'll
show you has to do with basically just
optimization because PBS cannot just
find errors in our code it can actually
help us optimize that card as well
what I'm gonna do is write a very simple
function it's going to maybe return this
kind of entity struck that we have so
suppose I have a struct called entity
I'll then write a function called Lord
entity which potentially is supposed to
just load the entity but what I'll do is
I'll purposely just make it return null
pointer all the time so all this
function really does is returns null
pointer it's just supposed to serve as a
very very simple example of some of the
stuff that PBS studio can actually
detect so I'll go ahead and try and
maybe call that function here as you
might in some example code here and then
a pretty common check here is to check
to see if entity is null or not and I
can do that by just writing if entity
now in this case this check is
absolutely not needed we know that
entity is always going to be null we
might as well not even have a branch
because that's going to needlessly slow
down our code we don't need to do that
we know that it's always going to be
null and this is something that PBS
studio can actually detect if we go
extensions PBS to do check current file
and you can see that it actually tells
us that expression entity is always
false this is always false this
expression now the benefit here is
twofold if in fact it is supposed to be
always false
then you can just remove this branch
completely and you've saved yourself a
branch and at the very least if the
compiler does in fact get rid of that
you've cleaned up your code considerably
however if it's not supposed to be
always false this is going to lead to
you uncovering an actual error in the
code that you've written because looking
at this clearly this is not always
supposed to be false low-density is not
supposed to always return null so you
can go back and take a look at your
implementation and make sure that you've
actually written the correct code and
that I think is super useful okay so
hopefully that was a little bit of an
introduction to static analysis and PBS
studio this is definitely a huge topic I
might cover more of this in the future
it's just one of those things that in
practice is gonna help you a lot more
than if I just theorize about it all the
time you need to actually download PBS
studio and give it a go now normally PBS
studio have a 7 day free trial available
however they've been nice enough to give
you guys a 30-day free trial all you
have to do is check out the
in the description below and use the
appropriate code the other great thing
about PBS studio is that they have a ton
of really really really useful articles
on their website I'll link some of my
favorites in the description below as
well but just check out their blog I
mean they they literally have so much
content on there that's a good read even
if you don't choose to use PBS to do
some of the errors that their software
has attempted and if they've done a
write-up about has just been really
helpful in general just detailing some
really hard to find in critical bugs
that you probably wouldn't have even
thought of so definitely give PBS studio
a try running on some of your own
software projects and let me know in the
comments section below what errors it
picks up I really am interested to see
all the different stuff that it can
actually detect I hope you guys enjoyed
this video and I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]